[Musica]
tu hai un problema è quel problema si
chiama facebook ogni anno centinaia di
migliaia di persone entrano in questo
tunnel e si perdono
per sempre l'unica cosa che si propaga
la stessa velocità e che provoca gli
stessi danni e la pellagra pensateci un
attimo cosa me ne frega devi sentire
delle persone che credevate morte se non
vi siete sentiti a 10 anni ci sarà un
motivo
[Musica]
noi possiamo aiutare e ricordati che non
sei solo il mio ragazzo io glielo
riescono più a capire non riusciamo più
a comunicare a parlarci se ne sta pure
amore chiuso niente quella maledetta
camera e dici che ha incontrato antonio
alberto luca ciao andrea ma chi cazzo è
andrea
[Musica]
vinco e mi ha rovinato la vita
scusate isolato per pensare
facebook ti potrebbe trasformare in
persone come
come lei
o nel peggiore dei casi
e mi raccomando fa la cosa giusta usa
internet solo per masturbarti
[Musica]